why would you wait
five ten years to come out and why would
a man that is Rich and Famous need to
rape anybody I mean like guys let's just
put two and two together unlike Drake
have women throwing hundreds of broads
out on stage why would a guy need to to
assault or rape anybody in order to get
sex
that's having it thrown at him 24 7.
this is the equivalent okay this is the
equipment
of me being a billionaire and getting
accused of robbing a bank I I don't
believe this this is the same thing they
did the date this is the same thing
they've done to Noah Clark this is the
same thing that they've done to comedian
politician
basically any guy that decides to tell
the truth and go against the mainstream
narrative they throw all these
allegations at